PROFESSOR: OK, Let's
use the last 10 minutes
to discuss an application.
So that's our Fermi
golden rule there.
Let's leave it in
the blackboard.
So the example I will
discuss qualitatively
will not compute the
rate for this example is
auto ionization, or also
called Auger transitions.
So we imagine of--
I think the reason this
example is interesting
is that there is continuum
states, sometimes in cases
that you would not
think about it,
or you wouldn't have
thought about them.
So let's assume we
have a helium atom.
So you have two electrons,
z equals 2, two protons
and two electrons.
And I will assume that we
have a hydrogenic state.
So you see the Hamiltonian
of this whole ,
atom there's a P1 squared over
2n plus a P2 squared over 2n,
roughly for each electron,
plus or minus e squared over r1
minus e squared over r2, and
then plus e squared over r1
minus r2, which is
the Coulomb repulsion.
So that's roughly
the Hamiltonian
you need to consider,
at least to 0-th order.
And let's assume this is
H0, and let's consider
states of this Hamiltonian, H0.
So these are hydrogenic states.
We treat each electron
independently.
And therefore, the
energy levels, E
are defined by two principle
quantum numbers, n1 and n2,
and they are minus 13.6
eV times z squared.
The energy of an electron
in a nucleus with z protons
gets multiplied by z
squared there times 1
over n squared, and 1 squared
plus 1 over n2 squared.
Those are the principle
quantum numbers.
And z squared is equal to
4, because z is equal to 2.
So this number
comes out at 54.4.
So here is e of n1 n2 is minus
54.4 eV, 1 over n1 squared
plus 1 over n2 squared.
OK, let's look at the
spectrum of this atom.
I'll erase here.
So let's draw a line
here, put 0 here.
Ground state.
n1 is equal to n2 is equal to 1.
The ground state
is at minus 108.
That's a state that we call
state 1, 1 for the two quantum
numbers being 1 and 1.
OK, so then we go on,
and look what happens.
Then we have, for
example, the state 2, 1.
And the state 2, 1 is
going to be less bound,
because instead of having 1
and 1, you have 1/4 plus 1,
so it's less bound.
3, 1, 4, 1.
How about infinity 1?
Infinity 1.
That's n1, the first electron
being super Rydberg atom.
It has its quantum
principle quantum
number so high that it's 0,
and you have the other electron
here with a 1.
So this is at 54.4.
The infinity 1 is here.
One electron is bound
in the one state.
The other electron
is out very far.
It's almost free.
You could have it free.
If it goes free, we'll
have some more energy.
So actually, after
you go here, there's
a continuum of states, a
continuum of states over here
in which every electron here
is an infinity and an electron
with some momentum, k.
And these are still
states that are
here can be represented
by energies in this range.
And then, eventually, you
have even this goes on here.
So there's a lot of
bound states there,
and then we can continue.
How about the state--
so I've put here infinity.
I'm sorry, not infinity, k.
I will put it here
like k times y,
because the other state
remains in the 1 s.
So one electron-- here both
electrons were in the 1s state.
And here 2s, 3s, infinity.
So one electron
remains in the 1s.
One electron is free with
some momentum over there.
Then, for example,
consider the state E 2, 2.
This happens to be a 2 and a 2
is a quarter, a quarter, 1/2.
So this is at minus 27 eV.
It's right here in the middle.
This is the state 2, 2.
After the state 2, 2 sets in,
there is a state 3, 2, 4, 2, 5,
2, infinity 2.
So one term is infinity.
The other is 2.
So it's one quarter.
And infinity 2 is that
the hydrogen level, 13.6.
And after that infinity 2,
there is a new continuum
of states that has some
momentum and are still in 2.
And there's going to be an
infinite number of continuums
arising here when you consider
one electron and the other one.
So what is our other transition?
This was at minus 27.2.
The other transition we're
typically interested in
is this one in which you have
this discrete state overlapped
by the continuum of states in
which one electron is gone out,
and one electron has
remained in the--
has gone to the 1s state.
So I'll write it down here.
So what is the other transition?
We have precisely this
situation with indicate
that here in which
you have one state
surrounded by a continuum.
So the other transition, so
the line 2, 2, at minus 27 eV
is in the middle of the
infinity 1 continuum.
So we'll have a transition
into 2s squared--
that's this state,
that's the name of it--
goes to 1s times 3.
The e 2, 2 is going to
be E1 infinity plus E3.
And the e 2, 2 is minus 27.2.
This is minus 54.4,
and this is E3.
So E3 goes to 27.2 eV
for the free electron.
So how do we visualize this?
If you wanted to compute it,
and it's kind of a fun thing,
but we will not do it, you
think of the initial 2s state.
Have the atom.
The one is the two
electrons here.
And you think of them as having
an initial wave function,
hydrogenic, and then suddenly,
because maybe something
happened.
This 1s electron got
excited, and suddenly,
for an instant of time, the
two are there in the 2s.
And then this
interaction turns on,
and this is the v that makes
that transition from this 2s
squared state to 1s 3.
That has good matrix elements,
and this is going to happen.
And this is the
dominant transition,
because a radiative transition
in which one goes down here
is fairly suppressed.
It doesn't happen.
So this is our example
of an application
of Fermi's golden rule, and
we'll explore more next time.